okay II for this time Wow would be
wonderful if I can actually get back
into playing where I'm not having the
the missed mouse clicks that would be a
wonderful time saver okay so what do we
have here viana game max lang defense
I guess d3 and if the bishop place to be
for should I be afraid okay
I'm going to do what I'm actually gonna
play Bishop here or night here I'm gonna
play Bishop here let's see what Black's
gonna do to take or not to take is the
big big big question ah black says no
I'm not taking you and opening up the F
file for your look after your castled I
don't care about doubling your EEP on
zai don't want your rip to have any fun
when it's here okay I understand that if
you're listening are you understanding
that that's why black is not going with
the doubling of the pawns because this
guy I'll have a ton of fun ton of fun on
the F file so candidate moves Knight f3
92 I'm never really in a position to
capture this bishop with my night
because I end up in a fork but I'm gonna
still get in a position to just capture
and at least prevent a knight recapture
or a knight recapture and me maybe
having to deal with the knight sitting
there black may end up doing similar
with their bishop on e6 so I think now
is the time to chop this guy up and
let's see how black recaptures if Knight
here I think I'll take right away and
okay so because otherwise I run the risk
of being in a pins
so let's go night and now decision time
for this guy play here - pressure on
this pond or play in the center hmm I
hear I think eventually forces a pond
push or there might even be a d5 move in
response to it actually night here d5 I
could take and then take this sky
although it is a bit scary Knight f4
moves later on I don't know if I'm
really even threatening to take the pawn
I think d5 might be a good move so let's
go with this it's entering a pretty dry
position I am having flashbacks of a
game that I did play
I think blitz time controls I think it
was actually against windmill from a
while back and there was something like
my F pawn was able to get here I ended
up winning a an F pawn and then that
that was it but I think my opponent had
opportunities in that game to definitely
be equal so let me do this and actually
not open up the F file so let's tuck
this Bishop back and I need to get my
buck castled and as a continuation f4 so
now there's this tension I think is one
that we both do well to maintain I
capture the bishop black I'll have
playing the F file black captures my
bishop
I have play on the a file now this I
think is a slip-up because I could throw
in a check is that going to be
inconvenient to black I think it is I'm
actually going to run with that since
this pawn move two squares there is no
forming a b7 c6 structure to block that
guy out so now let me just castle and
hopefully I could put this to good use
here f4 is my idea and actually let me
think twice about that because my
bishops running the risk of getting
crushed and I don't like having that
happen he did his job well done you
chased the king away for a little bit
you stopped black from castling but is
it going to be enough to claim some
advantage Black has a bit of a space
advantage as pawn on d4 but with no
minor pieces on the board I mean these
guys are soon to be off I don't know if
them just having the major pieces alone
is enough to really show that this could
maybe be some advantage so I think this
is really the only direction to go in as
white to do anything I'm just I'm still
looking to have some play for my major
pieces my Brooks need to get doing
something I want to be cautious about
playing f5 because I give this square up
the e square but in return I get the a
file so let me actually retain this
pawns flexibility and if after pawn to
b5 then I could think about this move
and after takes I recapture and then
there's a home on a 5 and maybe I could
pinpoint the a6 pawn but if this
structure is persistent I don't know
what exactly to do like I'm a bit again
reluctant to be playing f5 in the
meantime how can I make small small
improvements because that's really all
I'm seeing right here ok so now I
actually have this and this is something
that black I believe should be shine
away from and it would seem that they're
preparing this no they're not they're
just guarding the pawns they're stopping
this advance so I'm Adam this is one of
these just I'm gonna move quick and do a
useful move flight square so my opponent
less than 2 I actually have a time edge
I may look into rook a 4 and then b4
stuff King here how could i stir up some
trouble how about
well let's see what black does in
response to that move know what it's
doing exactly but I want to give it a
whirl she's got some lateral movement so
I guess she could maybe pivot on d5 one
day but in you know if this is dropping
upon the Queen here is compromising the
structure in some way so I'm real I'm
really seeing this position definitely
get down to okay this is we're gonna
have a just a rook that's what I was
going to say just a rook King rooks and
pawns position take the Queen's we're
about even with time I think I I'm gonna
go with that so let's let's go and then
as a follow up what would I like to be
doing here oh I'm gonna do this actually
I could get upon a five I'm gonna make
some King improvements I think
let's go King what are you even doing
you're sitting home here let's go H pawn
you're not doing anything either so
these guys are out inching one step
closer to what to victory lane rook a 4b
for ideas opening up the B file
targeting this guy and I keep things
closed I think this is benefiting me and
well maybe it's not benefiting me or
maybe it is let me do this
and actually maybe this is a follow-up
if rook to c8 I might play this and then
rook a5 to b5 I get a pawn back I'm
gonna go with that
so this King yes it should be very
scared or should it yeah cuz these guys
could be passed really soon am I getting
trapped no not getting trapped okay
let's come over here
rook activity this is the newly opened
file or even with time there it might be
this pawn push to break up this but
we're not having that let me go with
more rook activity so I have the active
rooks my opponent is on the defensive
here this pawn is going down is it isn't
it if it's defended I play rook d7 I
think the only tries this or not I'm
gonna run with the grab this pawn I'm on
this one there's gonna be a rook check
but there's not much that black could be
doing now these these ponds are gonna be
passed
so let's come towards the center to
avoid the check 31 seconds each this
pawn is falling with the check and let's
trade a little bit rook trades let's go
here and okay and I just gotta move
quick here let's let's do this I want to
drop my if I have to drop a pawn I want
it to be my H pawn ok pawn push pawn
push with check how much time push I'm
looking for a rook check and then more
pawn pushes ok that's um let's go at
this pond now he can't be caught canny
okay now he can't be caught my queen is
there in time pin the rook and then give
a check and get the rook
I think that's it right no time but what
a tight game Wow good game a very good
game I think we've played at least once
before that was definitely the tightest
game really good really really tight the
whole way through so let's see this is
the Vienna game max Lang defense just
making certain of that and some
interesting decisions right here not to
take bishop to d4
I think there's um if black doesn't want
to take the bishop I think actually
bumping it or just yeah going backwards
is maybe better like why not go to the
b6 square and then you know then it's a
situation kind of like it happened in
the game where I went back to b3 the
corresponding squares b6 b3 if I take
you you get the half open a file so
maybe Bishop back to b6 is a bit better
anyhow we have that and again I'm for
some reason I'm feeling like Knight e 2
is met with d5 or something takes takes
and if I grab the pawn Knight f4 the
Queen hits my knight and is just having
pressure on g2 I can get very awkward
very quick for white so that's why I
went with the Knight d5 backup my bishop
and maybe just castle here although I
wasn't really able to exploit the King
position I think in this end game it's
maybe the computer would be saying light
is slightly better maybe but not not
really enough to show an advantage as
far as I could tell maybe maybe it's
okay to actually play King g8 King h7
and then play Queen g6 because I'm not
sure what to even do in the meantime now
in the game I ended up playing rook a
for an eventual b4 move but if this
Queen is still going to be around
on the board that's maybe something that
could be problematic like it's not
without allowing the rook play the black
rooks to have some play on the c5 I'm
going to playing that b4 push but I felt
it all right without the Queen's on the
board to be going with this idea rook a
for before so I think maybe just an out
compromise position recognize if black
is able to recognize and I believe we're
pretty much short on time at this point
but just recognizing that I really don't
even have anything
yes it's an improvement the eight the h5
square instead of the f3 square
well I mean what does she really think
she's doing from here okay she goes to
d5 so uh d5 Queen e6 I don't know if
it's needed to compromise the structure
like that so I don't know yeah
something's maybe off with that move
right because I have a passed pawn now I
I was seeing right here something with
black trying to undermine this structure
I think this is something to be looking
into this has to be broken down quickly
before I can be giving check to the
black King and because it wasn't black
is really on the defensive now saw this
in that later in this very very late
stage of the endgame look into that a g5
move I think that was an important pawn
to be making